welcome to this video play five minute
game on icc against past glory never
played him before well it's not a new
account current name in them no name
brownie ok we gotta close the soul Ian
and I had played a six before let's go
with the normal line knight c6 yeah well
this is this i have this i had only
recently and then in a 15-minute game
and i remember that i really had lots of
trouble it wasn't this move it was a
capture um ok now with this i cannot
really i don't really think this this
can be too too too dangerous the
question is should i do Bishop to g4 and
exchange this not sure
okay now a 67 get this get this away
from my camp yeah I don't really want to
play six but Bishop g4 I mean he might
just take on c5 this was not very well
timed by me okay yeah it's not the end
of the world but probably not ideal hmm
now I can play click like we need seven
everything else felt
okay let's let's castle and yeah we'll
Bishop c-5m need to get rid of this
queen here jam it's not very comfortable
but it still feels reasonably reasonably
solid um yeah ticking is not a really
great maybe this young knight c5 Hanks
the Queen so you will probably take on
da now and after that it should be okay
while Knight b6 Bishop c6 it's fairly
fairly solid maybe even this year Knight
b6 rook p8 Bishop c5 I can play em
Bishop c 60 B should be five even know
yeah this should be okay unless there is
something terrible happening immediately
that's a very simplistic approach it
doesn't it bother me too much yeah well
this Bishop is doing nothing on g7
really and the night will of course also
be routed by five chan should i do that
now this looks e6 somehow helpful now
I'm not sure I want to want to be sure
that I get this space into play before I
right place g4
yeah this should be about equal I don't
really see any any big problems here for
me don't have a bad piece and you know i
mean i think i need to exchange this
it's a hard to do without orders
exchange need to get get activity maybe
it takes rook tags will be five can be a
move for a look-see for attacking the
polar form now it takes quite some time
okay let's first take here 93 is the
smooth maybe but not so sure but it
gives me some activity here against
their form but that's quite ok I mean
what does this move now it's not so easy
i also have g5 coming um okay well not
here
interesting
well that's a good move didn't
appreciate that properly I'm quite sure
what I should play here
maybe can you play a five year wow
that's not good
check time warning now he blundered in
exchange but not quite sure if it is so
great maybe maybe i can i can get the
porn without any any big problems like
this check check yeah that should be
okay Riley white resigned oh that's
early yeah okay I'll enter a lantern
he's got less time it is winning but
still people have usually prolong things
okay yeah oh this this was probably
highly critical a maybe yeah well this
means that 93 really wasn't a good idea
I mean okay I thought initially I
thought that this would be just good for
me but it's not the case one night g5 of
course just a good news i was i was
hoping for something like this which
quite obviously 95 prevents now this is
probably just not good i will the
computer is still giving this as a
sequel not bad though f six wins forward
completely plus 50 plus five is quite a
lot yeah I guess this six and I cannot
stop it e six takes f7 and breaks
through we are home
yeah that's that's a problem could if
white could have one would have 60 and
this is so this is probably playable in
a way ya desayunaste exchange some play
the game with it yeah easy come easy go
around he had it was it was very much
equal I believe but he lost his way yeah
tiim this wasn't good Bishop h6 is a
very good move here that the computer is
quick to point out f4 is hanging and g3
this age for the very nice position hmm
that's it's very very good move but I
was just ahead just put the bishop on a
fade to to get it to c5 so I didn't
consider Bishop h6 at all and Jim here
it's uh it's just equal alright thanks
for watching